higher interest rates could also mean
higher mortgage payments for many
homeowners now that is by design the fed
is hoping to pump the brakes on a major
trend upwards in the cost of a home
according to zillow the typical home
value in this country is up nearly 40
percent since march of 2019 that's
partly because there are far fewer
houses on the market these days more
than 50 percent less that's a big drop
mark straussman traveled to nashville
tennessee where this is becoming a big
big problem for people with lower
incomes
in nashville's white hot real estate
market this is cool too realtor shane
talent says new listings under seven
hundred thousand dollars generate
feeding frenzies if that house hits the
market
there's likely 50 showings in the first
24 hours and 10 to 15 if not 25 offers
on it despite rising interest rates
nashville's real estate boom has no end
in sight typical home values in metro
nashville jumped more than 30 percent in
one year the typical monthly home
payment shot up 50 percent
if you're going to come here get here
now because it's not getting any cheaper
north nashville is part of the new
nashville turning over fast often no
longer affordable to the old nashville
this used to be the food pantry tomorrow
stacy downey will shutter the little
pantry that could
food for 300 families a week mostly
fixed income and working poor we told
them they could rely on us
and
now they can't
the little pantry that could can't
anymore its five year lease wasn't
renewed in a neighborhood where
developers and investors keep scooping
up properties
you're telling me in the entire city of
nashville there wasn't a single
place to go no not for what we could
afford absolutely not
exactly teacher jahan strange relied on
stacy's pantry to help feed some of her
students
the most important thing that she has
given here is hope
where does that help go now
i don't know
i honestly don't know inside all this
city's prosperity there's also pain
for cbs mornings mark strassman
nashville